ni rente lui sauva les lauriers sont
coupés
la belle avait ramassé en prouvant la
danse
casimir casimir tu mens 3 qu'est ce que
c'est j'ai un message pour toi un pour
moi un message secret toi comme les
agents secrets pour ça c'est inquiétant
elle ne soit pas bête c'est simplement
quelques mots de françois sur une
feuille de papier 4 pour moi pour toi ta
vie moins chère casimir ap six mois ben
je serai correct eu la gentillesse de me
garder les ballons jusqu'à mon retour je
vais jusqu'au port de l'île pour
chercher un ami
le clown pique nique aux qui vient nous
rendre visite
tu as entendu julien accueillis bravo
comme aurait dit un vrai clown un bayou
magma qui a omis c'était encore mieux
cette fois c'est pas moi quoi voilà
voilà
bonjour voila j'ai suivi les clowns du
moungo c'est lui on n'a pas revu mon âme
niveau en trois sets robin monsieur pour
nico il y a juste l'aller vous chercher
autant vous conduire chez nous et aller
au bois on me cherche un ouais vous
conduit chevaux puis saint qui sera non
non c'est nous nous et mieux noyer vous
alors à l'eau vous a demandé - j vous
aussi
casimir et voilà les enfants bonjour mes
petits amis veuille ou value pour les
petits amis comment mais trouvez vous to
roll comment trouvez vous les médias
mais c'est joli et les ivy vos costumes
plus 6 équipe 6 titres et si monsieur
pique nique bien alors vous avez eu une
très belle fleur et l on donne moi je
t'admire ronnie fla-flu les bosquets
casimir les petits revenus les petits
amis celui de front ce fut le roi mais
aussi bien fait salon bonsu états unis
on se casse une île genoux vous madame
nous ne vous permet pas d'aller manger
tu admires tanner gens vous fait un
balai
qu'est ce que c'est trop
chez ces dangereux vous comparez
parlement ou et monsieur papa nouveau
bon bah alors d'accord - beaumont paris
connue que moi le grand pique nique au
gvt est allé della bella jusqu'à là bas
les kiosques les madmoizelles julie sol
et ne pardonnent sur une carte d'or sur
une corde raide
je pique niqueurs nous n'avons pas de
filets ici ce que ça change
mais le grand pique nique au travail sa
ville est à 20 est sacré pour les
enfants écartez vous attention attention
attaque mieux
et hop là le technicien attention' jolie
karine et l'entrée en hiver
ouf c'est cool qui menace il est temps
de pelouse les bananiers montali mois
donc vendre des noms commencent à 7
c'est trop facile un nom et pourquoi
monsieur états unis parce que l'ase
hauteur de la corde elle n'était pas
réglementaire peut-être mais ce n'était
pas prévu dans le panneau
voyez nommément vraiment là c'est pas
juste comme ça vous avez triché là je
voudrais bien que françois soit là pour
juger ce pari franchement vous alliez
voir françois mademoiselle julie a bien
tonné regarder et le présente pour vous
mettre dans une journée
regardez bien qu'est ce qu'on va voir
les parents soit acharné pendant 1
journée
est-ce qu'ils savent qu'il a prôné place
alors vous aussi regarder chez vous les
petits amis c'est par tous les grands et
que les corps les droits des clowns de
la corde raide
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce qui se passe on est alors
c'est pas un vrai clown je crois le halo
incitons font masser françois alaux
qu'il un pique nique aux suites nikon et
bien pique nique aux n'existe pas je
m'étais déguisé en clown pour voir si
vous me reconnaîtrez y est souvent
maquillage de clown président otaries
soit jamais reconnu alors tu m'as fait
tout ça ça vous gagnez 3 bonbons mais
non mais non casimir vas tu peux les
garder tes bourreaux
bon ben écoutez moi je suis pressé je
m'en vais aussi parce que j'ai aussi on
a mis à aller chercher au port et à la
mort à tout à l'heure
et ben voilà je me suis démaquiller je
ne suis pas encore changé mais je suis
en pleine forme
papa tu sais moi je trouve que c'est
décevant qui n'existent pas pique nique
aux techniques au moins on se serait
bien amusés ensemble en fait pas vain ça
m'étonnerait pas qu'il revienne qui doit
au fait tu n'as pas vu casimir
ah non puis titre c'était bizarre cette
histoire d'amis qu'il allait chercher au
port là tout à coup c'était très court
il maintient bonjour les petits sapins
vous voulez bien jouer avec moi on va
faire un genre faut militer midi midi
mais diable bonjour quasiment 3 4 qu'est
ce que ce serait mais mais vous m'avez
reconnu malgré mon déguisement de clown
en salle en rond
[Musique]